hey everybody welcome back to LED live
we got a new look like this I love it
today I'm excited to bring you this
topic but before we get into that we
want to remind you guys you know what
for those that have supported us check
out our patreon thank you for everyone
that has jumped onto patreon and
supported us and held forwarded us the
ability to be able to do this account
it's such a blessing and you guys are
part of our team as well I also want to
remind you a lot of people call and ask
about like where do we get your DVDs and
and we make actual documentaries on a
lot of topics that we cover things that
we haven't put on our YouTube page so
you're welcome to check those out you
can get them on our website little light
Studios TV or check out our vimeo we got
digital downloads you can watch them
there and of course don't forget we sell
t-shirts like what these guys are
wearing right here yeah this is one of
the ways that you can help support our
ministry we have a passion for share in
the gospel with simple things like
wearing a t-shirt and and you know
putting putting a Christian theme on
that so check those out they helped us
continue forward
so here's today's topic do you guys
think video games are bad absolutely not
all right find out on this episode of
LED live
[Music]
there is actually a lot of research that
is come out in the news that talks about
there's some very positive things with
videogames and so we're gonna talk about
that today because I think there's a lot
of misinformation and we're gonna find
out in this episode are videogames
100% bad so who's controlling who have
you guys played with these Michelle what
is this controller okay I'm just
checking just checking to make sure you
guys know what this thing is have you
ever played with one of these do you
know that I have I have actually never
played with this controller ever how do
you game ps3 to you know Nintendo which
was pretty much my my heyday my video
game expertise and and then I had a Sega
Genesis for a tiny moment but I never
got into the video game world and but
we're gonna get into this what do you
think the average age is of video game
players average thirty seven twenties to
a nice yeah I think I think I have a
good educated guess yes yes actually you
are correct this is from statisti and
their average highest demographic is 18
to 35 but actually 35 and above is the
highest demographic that plays like the
biggest chunk of video games I found
this very surprisingly to that there's a
lot of people 21% of all video gamers
are 50 years and older significant
people playing video games right so I
want to share with you a little bit
there's a guy named kind of Kazi Yoakam
no I'm gonna totally butcher this
there's a guy named Kazunori Yamauchi I
think I said that correctly no no cousin
or the Moche there you go yeah mausi
alright so this guy was one of the
design
of a game called gran turismo and when
he came out with this game he really
wanted it to be literally like you were
playing or what like you were driving a
real race car and this is somebody
that's been through their nissan
training facility and within a short
amount of time actually went on and
jumped into a real race car check this
out I think my competitive spirit yeah
it has come from my from my dad's and I
was a footballer and them he's always
wanted me more like my younger brother
to be the best we can be
we were just a competitive family I had
never experienced driving a sports car
on a track before GT Academy I mean fast
as I've been is probably ninety miles an
hour and loads of it the competition was
open for six weeks at that time so for
two weeks solid I was just pounding
around this one track on this one car
and to get a top 20 time the final race
there was four of us left there was no
real pressure because Kostas loving
every moment of the of the whole
competition I didn't want it to end and
the game of kit but we'll walk through
the paddock and just knowing in myself
that I can compete confidence that's the
biggest thing and you soon get to learn
that
not confident in your ability you're not
doing anywhere
in racing five years and I'm now at
stage where I feel I can compete at a
very high level remember second place so
I find it's pretty amazing that you
could literally play a video game and
then jump into a race car and actually
compete with real racers he has ever
played any surgery video games yes yeah
you've taken out a few hearts I don't
remember what I remember is like
stitching people together in did you
kill the patient so they're starting to
use video games in teaching and training
and surgeon surgery because actually
what it's doing is allowing the surgeons
to try and test different things with
obviously no risk to the patient there's
a lot of articles on the internet that
talk about how the medical world is
beginning to incorporate video games
into their education system of course
they are actually even using robotics
and this article here is talking about
how they're starting to actually build
the controllers for the robotics in the
same shape that people play video games
reason being the article says is because
people are so familiar with this already
that they can then go and do these crazy
surgeries but can you imagine like you
know if you're sitting at home and you
become this amazing surgeon or something
you know everything's got over the end
of your bedroom or something like I'm
right right I mean that's pretty that's
that's pretty wild
here's what this article says if we want
to change the perception of healthcare
past something that's old-fashioned in
archaic we should take the best
technology in our field and use it to
push the limits of what's possible in
healthcare for example the multi-million
dollar health monarch surgical platform
used the lies utilizes controllers that
would not feel out of place than an Xbox
or a PlayStation very interesting this
particular doctor here i'ma show you a
clip here where he's actually testing
some some students that he has that have
some surgical experience and then he's
going to take some people who literally
have had no surgical experience but just
are really good at video games
and put them at a task against each
other and see which one will outperform
the other one we wanted to see their
results comparing through our physicians
and they did slightly better and pretty
much the same but slightly better than
our physicians in training and some of
those physicians are training they
already participated in an actual cases
and it tells me that this computer games
helps a lot to transfer the knowledge
and skills gained from the computer
games easy to implement into the robotic
surgery no mention what he's playing I
mean I don't know how that helps with
surgery really like hearing you
literally like knocking the guy's teeth
outside you could like put them back in
or something I don't know but I find it
very interesting that he found this guy
found that the people who had no
surgical experience but just were really
good at video games actually
outperformed his people who had surgery
experience so that's kind of very
interesting what happens when you have a
stroke you lose motor function why
though why do you lose motor functions I
think part of your brain guys does part
of your brain dies right so the brain is
made up of electrical impulses that
basically just go in a certain pathway
right so your language your motor skills
all those things are basically little
electrical impulses that follow in that
same path
but when part of the brain dies what
happens then there's no longer that
pathway there so they found a really
good way to retrain the brain is
literally hand them some video games and
they can remake those pathways inside of
the brain they also have found in the
elderly that if they let them play video
games
it actually can increase their lifespan
which I found was very interesting you
guys ever played Wii tennis Yeah right
you know I think there is some really
fun video games systems out there we
tennis was kind of a neat thing because
it really incorporates your body
movement with it and stuff like that
so they gave this particular a Nintendo
device to some elderly
people and in just plain for 2 hours a
week they were able to slow the decay of
their mental decay and natural aging
process which I found found was pretty
interesting here's somebody that is
actually had a stroke and they're having
her play a little video game and you
guys can kind of see what how this is
kind of working out so they have a big
sort of screen in front of her and they
have like these butterflies that are
coming and she's supposed to like knock
down the butterflies and just by that
action alone that can help her retrain
herself to walk but this stroke patient
is able to totally rehabilitate and this
is one of the better ways to do it
why because video games are actually a
really great teaching tool this article
right here in medical daily talked about
a little game called cut the rope so a
game that you would think is just a
waste of time I mean you anybody got
games on their phone do you ever play
games on your like your stand in line so
much playing grammarians yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean there's a reason why those
little games are popular I mean people
are standing around in a line and they
play these little games right well this
particular game called cut the rope this
article in medical daily was talking
about it and they found that people
after playing 20 hours of cut the rope
could concentrate and switch between
tasks 60% better and 33% faster than
those that didn't play it so it's just
like training your motor skills or
something right yeah so it's like you
know you think about it your your your
brain is having to do an action
your hands are having to do an action
it's hand-eye coordination and you know
you're thinking very fast and rapidly on
what your what decisions you're gonna
make and then you're having to like
actually tell your hands to do those
actions or whatever so that that's a
that's a skill building process and
there's no doubt I believe the medical
world is has you know come across this
information multiple times that yeah
there there there's positive things to
train in your brain in a quick manner
the gaming institutions are now kind of
like also
starting to create content for the
workplace and what what I mean by this
is like there is a lot of jobs where
they would actually you know train you
with putting a video sitting down
watching the video and trying to learn a
skill and stuff and people would just
tune them out especially everybody has
phones now and so it's like you're
checking your internet and you know I
mean the level of distraction that comes
in to jobs the workplace now today is is
10 times worse than I remember when I
was a kid and so to compensate for this
they found that a way to keep their
attention and to also teach them
whatever skill they're doing is to give
them a little video game to play and
then they can incorporate whatever that
company is trying to teach that person
to do and make sure that they actually
did it because there's a score going on
and all that comes out like flip the
burgers yeah literally right so listen
to this and in this article it says the
University of California Children
Hospital in San Francisco
gamification was used to prevent
hospital-acquired infections it was
estimated that these cause up to a
hundred a hundred or is it a hundred
thousand patient deaths in the United
States each year and to motivate nurses
to be more careful and to to take more
careful measures when working with
patients the hospital implemented a
gratification app to complete in the
workplace what a time to be alive
right you know what I mean it's like
people are dying here play this video
game I mean but it's interesting you
know there's three types of learners
there's the kinesthetic learners you
know movements there's auditory people
like to listen and in the visual so
incorporating this something that's
kinesthetic that's movement which is
most of the population anyway I can see
how that's beneficial in the long run to
more people that's right what's
interesting to me though about that is
is years ago this is the 1800s I believe
they discovered as hand washing was the
single most important thing that they
found that they could do to help the
spread of infection and now we've gotten
to the point where it's like are we not
as careful anymore you know we just yeah
you know everything so
clean right and yeah we're taking it for
granted and now we have to gamify the
thing and and bring that back into the
oven humans are funny I know but I mean
think about the level of where this this
this potentially could go I mean what if
your kids are like I'm gonna go to a
gaming school where I'm gonna just learn
math and everything by just playing
video games like my kids they play on
this app called Starfall you ever heard
of this thing so it's basically a whole
website that is kind of for lack of a
better term games and they teach you
like math skills and word skills and
stuff and a lot of the public school
systems have implemented this in and if
you go to school they can give you a
login and the kids like literally sit
there and they play games and they learn
all sorts of words like we used to play
number crunchers yeah you know we used
to do what they call flashcards you know
those are like you'll hold up a card and
now they just play video games you know
I mean it's pretty it's it's pretty wild
so science daily they talk about this
use of video games in the workplace as
well teaching all these different skills
a lot of articles on the internet that
talk about this the military the
military's used video game systems to
basically train their their military
operates and and the military realizes
that there's a lot of very dangerous
situations you just can't immediately
put someone in and if they've never
disarmed a bomb before you're not gonna
like go sit them down in front of a bomb
and be like just make sure it's the red
one you know it's like they teach you
very complicated situations in dangerous
situations using simulation and VR
they've learned how to fly helicopters I
mean very complicated things this is an
actual simulator that you use to train
with dismounted soldier training just
one of the ways the US Army is
developing the 21st century American
Warrior
it's a 57 million dollar system unveiled
for the army over the summer by a
company called intelligent decisions
soldiers trained for real-life combat
scenarios in a virtual space so you can
go into this this system and train on
any kind of environment urban woodland
desert depending on the needs of the
leadership of what they want to train
for ahead um and like senses detect your
motion so whatever is coded to be
whether it's coded to be a grenade or
binoculars or whatever so you hold it
there to activate and you just make the
motion of throwing the grenade and then
you'll still throw grenade the 15 pound
backpack processes each action sending
soldiers data out to a network so they
can operate as a team
one dead bad yaar in the hallway
you're talking to each other you're
moving in real-time you're seeing what
they do they see what you do just like
you would in any other kind of virtual
environment although it seems like a
video game
virtual missions can make live training
more efficient saving time and money
they can run through it and then if they
say oh let's try that again it's
basically just a matter of a few clicks
and you're you're reset there's not
moving everybody back into position
there's no repositioning of vehicles
there's no fueling up right there you're
saving money time fuel ammunition so
these guys here are talking a little bit
about this relationship between the
military and the video game industry
there's long been a relationship of the
two and the video game world actually
gets a lot of funding for some of these
video games from the military so why
would the military be interested in
helping fun video games first off and
then being involved in it recruiting
because it's a teaching tool recruitment
and it's a teaching school watch this
video clip I would have to say I mean a
lot of us are familiar with the
relationship between Hollywood and the
military-industrial complex like known
as the military entertainment complex
they often work together they have this
close relationship to push maybe certain
perspectives or viewpoints on war can
you tell us a little bit more about the
relationship between the military
industrial complex in the gaming world
why would the military
spend time and resources on video game
development well interesting thing I
mean one of the things that's really
interesting back the military
entertainment complex in Hollywood is
quite often it's actually concealed from
the public so in other words you get a
journalist for example and it often is
journalists who expose these
relationships but it's unusual for the
industry to celebrate them now what's
really fantastically interesting and
quite different about the games industry
is they normally seek to work with the
military to make their games more
authentic and they actively celebrate
that as part of the marketing campaign
so if you look for example at the Call
of Duty games or the recent Medal of
Honor rebooted franchise or battlefield
all of those games these massive series
that are played by millions millions of
people every year all of them are made
with the active collaboration of
military advisors and consultants but
also they're made with the tacit support
of the military for example in the usage
of technology so you get to fly an
attack helicopter for example driver out
and in a tank and so on and so forth and
all of those things are you know that
you're like able to do that because the
military acquiesce is in you using their
technologies in these games so
authenticity which is crucial to the
gaming industry comes specifically out
of those relationships and that is quite
different in terms of the way that it's
publicly celebrated compared to the film
industry which as I say like in the
superhero films they're always made with
the military but seldom is that
celebrated in quite the same way by
bringing the war right into your living
room right into your living room I mean
can you imagine like when you're playing
these video games the military has
advised them on all of the technical
details of this I mean it is as if you
are going to war right people come back
from war messed up because they see
these kind of things right and we're
kind of hand in this technology to
people going hey this is as close as
it's gonna get to like blowing people's
heads off here you go have fun here's
the keys like that to me is a little bit
alarming don't you think it's it's a
double-edged sword you know because
it depends on what you're doing with it
obviously you know the shooting people
is is probably not what you want to
release here the general public but you
know learning how to fly a plane or a
helicopter or something like that
you could really further your skills
towards a career or you know being very
helpful so definitely there's a how you
use it aspect and all of that I agree I
agree so the military is not shy about
this relationship they have lots of
details on the internet you can find out
which video games have been funded by
which military operations and it's it's
pretty alarming that some of the top
video games have really had this
symbiotic relationship so I found it
really interesting as I was kind of
doing a little bit of research on this
they started actually having a decline
in people wanting to sign up for the
military which is interesting because
now you know we're putting so much of
this out into society so the military
got really smart they said hey we need
to entice people to come back to sign up
to the military so one of the greatest
ways was to put these videogame systems
where there's a bunch of kids and where
is it where is there a bunch of kids in
the mall listen to this the world's most
expensive video game millions of dollars
to recreate the effect of shooting a
machine gun from an army helicopter
there's even a wind effect
it's what they call an experience center
the latest recruiting tool for the US
military has been placed in the middle
of a suburban shopping center in the
city of Philadelphia the target young
people who may not be old enough to
serve but could begin to get a taste of
the action
the main attraction of this new
recruiting centers of the US military
before 13 years or older can come and
forget to ride a simulated Humvee and
should simulated rifles and they're
given a mission they can shoot at people
who come to attack them and they lose
points if they kill civilians the
ability to watch soldier profiles there
are soldiers here to give the teenagers
more information about army life but
unlike normal recruiters the salespeople
are dressed like everyone else what
we're doing is giving them a virtual
glimpse of what some of the things
soldiers might do so we don't hide the
fact that the military can be dangerous
you see that in the video games but some
of the people we met expressed concern
that these games might give teenagers
the wrong impression about the realities
of war I don't think younger people know
the difference between dead and alive
really right now I think would be really
cool to see here it would be something
saying like there's a difference between
a game in real life so while you're off
shopping in the mall and your teenage
kid is running around by himself this is
potentially something that he could be
exposed to I mean 13 is insane and
there's completely desensitized like
it's just like a daze over over their
face right and it's interesting if if
they shoot a civilian is it they lose
points right it should be kicked out of
the game right you know what I mean wow
like you just lose points but nothing
really bad is gonna happen to you
because you know you're just gonna walk
out this door at the end of the day
anyway right and I don't think there's
much that we could do to really prepare
you know the mind for hey that person
just lost their life you know I mean
like they they could never continue
forward past this moment and you were
the one that chose whether they lived or
died I guess you kill the person you
have together like this virtual funeral
and see his wife and kid
leaping and stuff yeah you know
something like that would be crazy to
like introduce and try to like you know
show the reality of it so all of this
killing that a lot of people are playing
in video games right it's got abducens a
guy that's that's he's written a couple
of books on the art of killing and he
actually is is really working with the
military and working with the police
because they it's very difficult to take
a very healthy individual put a gun in
their hand and have them aim at somebody
that they don't know all of us have this
block inside of us to not pull the
trigger and so in order to do this they
have to actually psychologically train
these people to be able to do that and
they put safeties on it so listen to
this whenever we turn on the news we're
bombarded with horrific stories in fact
according to the FBI statistics there
were nearly 15,000 murders in 2015 alone
what is behind this lieutenant colonel
Dave Grossman is pointing the finger to
videogames is here to discuss his new
book assassination generation video
games aggression and the psychology of
killing and I think this is a must read
for parents especially parents of young
children absolutely let's talk about
your background a little bit yeah why
such a personal project for you
you know I began studying the topic of
killing I wrote the book on killing
Marine Corps commandant required reading
after 15 years of war Army and Air Force
recommended reading and when I began to
become aware of how we teach soldiers
and cops ago how how we have to
condition them right to be able to pull
the trigger to overcome the resistance
we realize that video games throwing the
same things to the kids you mentioned
before the psychology of killing what is
that you know there is a study of the
dynamics of getting healthy people to
pull the trigger right and we have found
my book on killing translated eight
languages half million copies sold now
same publisher
the the book on killing outlines how
we've got to be able to take soldiers
and cops make killing a conditioned
response it's BF Skinner
it's operant conditioning and and and we
know that we have a science to it we do
it to adults we do it very carefully
would put safeguards of discipline on it
but anybody's been in the Armed Forces
or law enforcement in the last 50 years
you don't shoot bullseye targets you
shoot a man-shaped silhouette a
photorealistic target we go to the
qualification range we're no longer
shoot at bullseye targets we shoot at
pop-up targets we hit the target the
target drops its BF Skinner it's freed
up operant conditioning right and a
frightened human being will do what he's
conditioned to do and like a pilot in a
flight simulator like a child in a fire
and that's exactly what a lot of these
video games are doing if you want to
check out some of our documentaries
we've made we've actually made three
documentaries called the controller
series you can pick them up on our
website little light studios TV and we
got lots of other documentaries on all
kinds of different subjects from
superheroes to cartoons and you name it
come check out our work on little light
studios TV that helps support what we do
as well so you got a lot of these video
games that are literally training kids
in the same way that he's clearly
trained the military and the police how
to kill people I mean you think about it
you're running around shooting targets
constantly what is all that doing to our
population general Reddy said like in
the situation where you're afraid you're
just going to react you're going to do
what you've been conditioning yourself
to do all the time and how will that
affect just everyday life that's right
scared and then boom you hurt someone
it's a very first response so video
games are an amazing teaching tool I
mean they can teach you how to race cars
they can teach you how to do surgery
they can retrain a who's had a stroke
and give them new motor skills right
we've seen that there is some very
clear-cut evidence that there's some
positive things to it but the question
then remains what are you playing
as a video game does it matter then if
you play something super like you know
we tennis all the time like literally
this is there a difference between that
and your
playing GTA running around shooting
people stealing cars that can you say
one type of game affects me but the
other one doesn't right right
so listen to this this is the top video
game sold what do you guys see here sins
are still ports and shooting ok sports
are still big shootings still big right
FIFA fortnight
Grand Theft Auto Call of Duty I want to
show you I want to show you a little
trend in 2009 what do you guys see as
the greatest chunk of the pie here
sports sports games right 19.6% of
sports games ok now look at this same
study done 2013 what is the largest
chunk now actions action games right
action adventure look at the the shooter
games okay now I'm gonna go back and
then I'll show you back in 9 2009
shooter games were 12% ok a few years
later four years later 20% okay now I
wanna show you 2016 what do you see
another job another huge jump in
shooters so there first-person shooters
are literally a biggest chunk of the pie
of what everybody's playing and of
course on that list that we saw what's
one of the most popular games is last
year that everybody's playing for 94.9
right i mean we've we've made a video on
fortnight the purpose of fortnight is to
be the last man standing the last man
standing to literally run around shoot
and kill everybody and be the last one
and dance over there floss oh no right
look at this Psalms eleven five says the
Lord tests the righteous but the wicked
and the one who loves violence his soul
hates mmm you know have you ever thought
of that literally God hates something
you know that's a harsh thing because we
in the Christian world we teach so much
that God is love right the very
definition of love the whole thing is
about love but there's actually
something that God hates
he hates violence why do you think he
hates violence
conflicts with the love exactly it's
opposite of love right but when you're
violent and you kill somebody what
happens
you took away one of his children can
somebody choose God after that point
no no what if they weren't ready to die
hmm that's why I believe God hates it is
because you're literally passing
judgment upon people immediately and
they're their choices made at that point
whatever whichever side of the fence
they stand on it's made so I think
that's why that's just those people who
commit it but those who love it as well
right right right good point Wow
that it's not just the people who do the
violence but the people that love the
violence like I want to dance over you
know yeah whenever I'm out speaking out
I asked my audience has a couple things
like we as a Christian should we love
something that God hates hmm
you know interesting is that I mean take
that in consideration if God says I hate
this shouldn't you be on the same page
as God a good point yeah he hates
violence in the video game says rated
mature for violence yes basically
telling you this is some God hates this
is correct the other thing I asked them
is like with games like fortnight or
Call of Duty or whatever you the
objective is to kill you know this evil
bad guy who's basically faceless
nameless you don't know who they are
they don't they don't mean anything to
you but if you were to change that
character into somebody you knew you
knew or maybe I asked him what if it's
just a bunch of little kids objective is
the exact same all you've done is change
the skin of the character and it's a
bunch of little kids and your goal is to
now be the last man standing does that
bother you okay does it make a
difference you are hitting the nail in
the head if you guys ever heard of a
video game called Bioshock yeah they
literally run around and the purpose is
to kill Christians seriously seriously
make it look like I'm not kidding later
or something
yes quoting somewhere and they're
singing they're singing like like little
kids like songs that you would sing in
like church or something like this yeah
Jesus loves me too and it's like oh
there's a Christian boom I mean it's
it's pretty nuts
so you
right if you actually change the skin
and it was like all just women and
children would that change the game if
it was literally your own family and
their faces were on there would that
change the game I would hope so
yeah are we are we all not one family
right we know in last days there's gonna
come persecution against Christians is
this like a simulation training
preparing people to accept that right
now let's discuss whether there is any
link between violence on the screen and
real violence with Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire and
retired Army lieutenant colonel
David Grossman who's authored books on
the psychology of violence Army Ranger
black belt and everything okay you when
you win just on that score it's great to
have you both on let's start with you
David because some of these games are
really wild I mean they're they're
pretty graphic pretty gory you know them
you know call of duty called a duty call
of duty I don't do any of these but what
Grand Theft Auto yeah they're simulated
simulated violence criminal simulator
murder seven Ramzi others like you know
some of these other killers Dylan
Klebold Eric Harris of Columbine were
steeped in these games Adam Lanza the
Norway killer trained on those he said
he trained on them 69 Dead Island in
Norway and it's been a year training on
video games to prepare himself his crime
the killer at in Florida he spent 15
hours a day on violent video games the
most all-consuming all-pervasive thing
in this guy's life are these violent
video games and it less than a year ago
the American Psychological Association
made a definitive statement there is a
clear unequivocal link between violent
video games final behavior that blood
pressure goes up their heart rate goes
up violent actions go up the data is
persistent and clear across many
different forms you cannot deny it
it is overwhelming Ben Shapiro I know
you're skeptical about a link from video
games millions and millions of people
play these video games I mean girls
aren't as into these video games I'm
sorry as boys are but but I think if my
son's had access to them I'm sure that
played them all the time because
something out the boys brain and these
games but why are you not worried about
it well I mean I'm not supremely worried
about it just because
the consumption these violent video
games has been going up continuously
since the early 90s and yet youth
violence has been going down since the
early 90s the correlation actually
doesn't fit as far as individual
instances I mean you can find patterns
in in spouts in very sporadic instances
among virtually all data sets but
there's been pretty mixed data about
this it's true that the American
Psychological Association recommends
that parents not allow their kids to
play these games I wouldn't let my kids
play these games because I think they're
immoral frankly but that should really
be up to parents I'm not sure the
government should be in the business of
stepping in in 2011 Justice Scalia and a
majority decision 5-4 found that it was
actually unconstitutional for the state
of California to regulate the capacity
of parents to be able to get these video
games for their kids or even for kids to
get them themselves without parental
permission you saw that as a Content
violation under the First Amendment so I
found it kind of very interesting Ben
Shapiro's thoughts on this I agree with
them yeah I would totally agree with him
as well yeah I was in his position as a
parent I wouldn't want my kids playing
that those games either but I wouldn't
want the government telling me that my
kids shouldn't play these games or be
taught certain things or be called
certain pronouns I totally agree
I totally absolutely agree I think once
the government kind of steps in and is
like now we're gonna teach you
everything moral and we're gonna you
know be the the depository of what you
can and cannot do then then I think
that's just leading us down a bad road I
think the ratings are helpful I think
those should be in place so that people
can make informed decisions yeah and
then it's then it's up to you what you
do and logically think about it like
here he's literally saying listen I
wouldn't let my kids play that why
because they're highly immoral right
think about that what the action is of
the video game and you know make a
decision based on that that's what I
would suggest this remote third John 11
says beloved do not imitate what is evil
but what is good he who does good is of
God but he who does evil has not seen
God mmm that's kind of interesting right
none of us have seen God but how do we
actually see God with our eyes by doing
what he's asking right loving each other
and when we do things that are evil you
know that
obviously is is well then we don't
understand what what God is asking for
us but I also think it's very
interesting don't imitate what is evil
yeah I even called it a murder
simulation gravitation simulation and if
you're imitating those things that are
evil then the Bible it has some pretty
clear evidence on what that means and
literally if you're drawn to those kind
of things and you like that and that's
fun for you then perhaps you don't have
a complete understanding of what God is
asking for us to do especially in a
Christian perspective I guess that's
kind of difficult the good question is
what is the purpose of playing this
particular game because telling that to
someone in the military I would see why
it's purposeful for them to play certain
simulations or certain games but if
you're sitting at home and your living
room on your couch and you're playing
these things and taking pleasure in it
what's your motive that's right
good point good point I mean obviously
you go into the military they need to
teach you how to operate a weapon you
know and you need to be able to learn
how to react otherwise you will die very
quickly out there so for sure definitely
in context the the motive behind it is
going to change so how much time do you
do you think people spend playing video
games is also what I would like to ask
you know do you think it's okay to play
a sort of a non-violent fun video game
but you just play for hours let's let's
just break this open what about
Minecraft you ever played Minecraft yeah
I didn't get too deep into it though man
I don't know it goes back to it depends
on the situation I mean you know if
you're coming home from school and
you're playing Minecraft and you sit
there and you play it on til it's time
for bed didn't do homework didn't
interact with your family and this goes
for adults too of course and I really
consider what you're doing but I would
want my doctor to sit down and play the
the simulation for until they got it
correct before operating on me for sure
so it depends on the situation yeah I
don't really necessarily I think there's
there needs to be a distinction between
a good video game and a bad video game I
do not actually believe that just
because it is an electronic game
that somehow that's made it evil like I
think that we tennis is a great time to
spend with your friends and play a game
with them and we bowling and whatever
like if that's the that's the kind of
activity you you have fun with your
friends
I see nothing necessarily wrong with
that but if you literally like you said
play Wii tennis every day now all of a
sudden you're not doing homework you're
not getting this he's on that becomes
the problems yeah for tonight went on
the news clip they said it was the
number four reason for divorce night
yeah an online divorce website says the
popular video game fortnight has been
cited in more than 200 divorces just
this year alone yeah well so then
there's a problem yeah so then the
amount of time then becomes an issue so
here's some statistics of how much time
people are actually spending and this
comes from Ford magazine so they're
basically saying that 18 to 25 is
spending on average 7 to 8 hours a week
does that sound like a higher low to you
guys it's an hour a day I would expect
it more on right so you're taking the
people who spend all day versus people
who spend no time at all and you're kind
of averaging it out yeah I don't know
how they're coming up with these
statistics 26 to 35 are spending eight
and a half hours so actually more I find
that kind of interesting you would think
that video games are in between the 13
to 20 age range you know it's like you
don't have very many responsibilities
you live at home your mom does your
laundry you're gonna feel a bit more
social still and these are good guys who
are married or kids
yeah we're scaping years ago 26 to 35 is
our workforce isn't it I mean these guys
are the ones that are playing and
putting the clock in the most hours
playing video games I found that kind of
interesting I found this kind of very
interesting to 60-plus are spending five
hours a week playing video games I mean
that's almost an hour a day yeah now you
think about that I mean like 60 plus you
know that's my parents age and you know
I just can't imagine my parents sitting
there like you know it got a video game
they liked it when they were 30 I guess
they still liked it now right you know
what is a what is a video game is like
solitaire pretty so yeah is that a video
game it is I can see that card game
that's true that's job that's true
but but look at this I want you I also
want to point this point out and this
survey was actually taken in 2018 as
well as 2019 and what do you see
definitely increased you see an increase
right so what is the population actually
doing playing more games playing more
games so this is why we're talking about
this this particular gentleman he
actually was a big video gamer and he
has just a little bit of personal advice
he's going to share a little testimony
of his involvement with video games and
how it actually really took a lot of his
younger years away and what he does now
video game addiction is something that
affects a lot of people especially a lot
of young people it was some that really
affected my life all throughout high
school in fact to give you guys an idea
I used to spend literally from the
moment that I woke up to the moment that
I went to bed playing video games I
would play it all day every day
I was totally immersed in it a lot of
days during school where I've skipped
school to go home and play video games
and for me it was a way to escape and I
think that's ultimately what I realized
that pushed me over the edge to want to
make the change and get away from it
because the reality was in my life at
the time when I was in high school I
wasn't a popular kid I didn't have very
many friends I was very shy I was very
insecure and as a result of that I would
get picked on you know I'd get bullied
from time to time I moved high schools
quite a bit and often times when you're
a weak target and you don't defend
yourself then you know people will
attack you even more because they know
that you're not gonna fight back and
they just kind of see you as a target to
elevate themselves to elevate their own
status and make themselves look cool so
for me I was very unhappy with my life I
was very depressed and so I used video
games to escape because video games is a
different world it's a different
universe where you can be whoever you
want to be it's like you can start from
scratch you can
create your own persona you can become
very good at it and you can meet your
needs from significance you can meet
your needs through connection and meet
friends and and feel like you're
important and unique and you're somebody
and that's what it was for the case for
me because I felt like a nobody in high
school I was insignificant to everybody
else but online you know because I spent
so much time doing it you know I I was
the best I remember certain games that I
played where I literally was the best
like I was the guy that people looked up
to I was like you know you know I take
out everybody and you know I was a part
of different team so whatnot and has
very skilled so I felt very confident
and I was meeting my needs and in
totally different ways and so I was kind
of living this two different worlds
there's real life and then there was
this fantasy world of online that didn't
really exist but it was just an illusion
and it was very detrimental for me and
it can be very negative to a lot of
people because for me what it was doing
it was it was causing it was forcing me
to escape the reality the truth of my
life and instead of confronting my life
the problems and the depression and the
issues that I had I didn't face it I
would just kind of distract myself and
as a result of that I would become more
antisocial right because the more time
he's played video games it's very
antisocial thing you're just in front of
a computer all day
it was just connecting me from real
people friendships um it was just it was
just also a waste of time when I look at
it as well because I looked at the years
that I spent playing video games in high
school like I look back and like man
what do I have to show for that I've got
nothing to show for that I spent so much
time and in my high school years is just
a blur it's like you know at the end of
your life or 10 or 20 years not gonna
remember these little video games and
these little adventures and stuff that
you went on that were so cool at the
time you're not building anything of any
value and I often think man if I spent
that time instead of playing video games
actually spent it improving my body or
my emotions or self-development or
building a business
man I would I would be like worth tens
of millions of dollars today if I had
started that process and the amount of
time that I spent doing that and just
replaced it with self-development okay
anything you guys noticed about this
nice place nice place he doesn't look
like he's hurting for work at this point
no just talking about how much time he
wasted just playing a video game pushing
a bunch of buttons when you die never
gonna look back and be like man I had
the highest score you know what could
you have done with all that time in the
real world you know what I thought about
what he said he brought up some really
interesting points that kind of really
made me think about when we get to
heaven I don't think anybody is gonna
get to heaven and be like I'm so glad I
played 50 hours of GTA right I don't
know you might have you like okay just
kidding but but you know III think that
the regret that we're gonna feel when we
get to heaven is why didn't I spend my
time doing something like better with my
time winning souls or being more
involved in my church or whatever and
it's like I think some of these things
at its core level it robs us of the
precious time that we have here on this
planet do you guys think it's possible
to become addicted to video game yeah
okay so there's a lot of people that
will argue with you on this but I'm just
gonna play you a couple of video clips
here you can make it make a decision the
World Health Organization officially
designated gaming disorder as a mental
health condition yes the World Health
Organization claiming video games are
addictive on the same page as alcohol
and gambling we're on your side tonight
learn more about how this disorder could
actually impact you and your family
we're talking mainly I think about your
kids joining us now is dr. John Kufner a
psychiatrist from financial of
behavioral health you know obviously
sitting in front of your TV a doctor
playing video games isn't his injury
says the nicotine alcohol that but what
are some of the side effects or negative
effects I should say about sitting in
front of that TV for hours I know if I
let my kids do it
it is potentially that dangerous a
couple years ago I read about some young
adults some 20 year olds something that
died after getting blood clots in his
legs after playing for like 48 hours
straight so Cheers it actually can kill
you so it can be that dangerous and it
can be that disruptive to your life like
it can interferes your ability to work
or maintain relationships stay in a
relationship or to supervise your
children I've seen kids that are
unsupervised because parents young
parents are gaming like so yes they can
be as disruptive as all those other
things know what questions can you ask
yourself to see if you may be addicted
to video games so there's a difference
between like an obsession and being
addicted and we talk about addiction
we're talking about this has gone so far
it's interfere with everything in your
life so it's somehow interfere with your
ability to work or maintain
relationships once those things are
written out cuz you're prioritizing the
game because you're having some sort of
withdrawal in between playing where you
have to you can't even be present the
moment is you have to get back to this
other virtual world and that's where
your obsession lives then that's when
it's an addiction and a problem well how
much responsibility falls on the parent
because as a parent with my kids wanting
to play the game especially fortnight
like most kids out there I tell my son
he has to stop playing and if he doesn't
I take the controller away I mean again
how much of this falls on the parent to
actually play a role in this almost a
hundred percent and I have a kid that
plays fortnight to so I'll tell you I
have this discussion in the office all
the time I have to tell teenagers I see
the worst fights over parent tried to
take away a phone a game console access
to a computer and the kid says she can't
take my phone he can't take my videogame
console you have to stay us in the
beginning those things are owned by the
parents I allow you to use it and you
can use it as much as I allow you to use
it and when you go on that I pull it
back and if you go beyond one too many
times we get out of the house so a
hundred percent of that has to be
controlled by the parents because it's
their property it is not the kids kid
does not have my cell phone my game
console my game he's bringing up a
couple of really good I think points
here is it's like we need to establish
from the very beginning because I hear
about this a lot as well going around
and speaking parents come up to us wow
my kid it's like he's totally into this
video game system and I can't pull him
away from it what should I do the parent
has to remember it's your system you
know you were the
you make the rules and when that line
gets crossed there's consequences to
that line you need to feel okay with
doing that with your kids and your kids
need to be aware of that yeah there's a
there's a tricky spot for parents too
though and that is the best scenario is
you start when they're young to not you
know develop that addiction but if
they're older let's say your kids like
16 17 by the time they hit that age if
they're already gone that far and now
you're asking yourself man maybe I
shouldn't let them play video games and
you know what do I do like in a year or
two they're gone yeah and now you're in
a position to where if you drop the
hammer
you're probably gonna ruin your
relationship and your influence along
with it and then they're gonna rebel and
they're gonna hate you and they're not
gonna listen to you so at that point
it's like a different plan right you
should you still have rules is it still
your house yes but you're dealing with
it from a different dynamic and you need
to first of all make sure that they know
that you love them and that you want
what's best for them and you need to
spend more time probably educating them
than trying to take everything away
they drew you know because it's not
gonna create the scenario you want say
your hundred percent agree you know of
course this is not like a friendship
situation it's a parent in a child right
but I think the parent being as open as
possible and really speak volumes to the
kid I know that from my perspective for
sure and maybe even sliding an apology
in there like listen I'm sorry that you
know I didn't see this earlier I didn't
come to you with this earlier but this
is the time right now and this is the
information that I've been presented and
this is what's going to be implemented
from now on you pray about it and
hopefully you know it goes smooth very
true very true and you know it like any
addiction just taking it away is not
necessarily the answer you know you have
to replace that with something so I
think the big thing for me that I drew
out of this was really
to recognize somebody that their normal
life duties take a backseat and this
then becomes the number-one priority in
your life that is a classic sign of an
addiction and so if you're questioning
anybody that's watching you're
questioning whether my child is addicted
or not
do they a get their normal life things
done kids have to do homework kids have
to clean their room kids have to do
normal chores and things that make them
responsible for life if all of those
take a backseat and gaming is the number
one thing your child might be addicted
no and if you're Christian you know you
have other things there should be time
set aside for prayer and Bible study you
know devotional time family time in
those aspects as well so it's not just
the normal everyday stuff there's other
things too that could be replaced and if
those are set aside for games well we
can see you bet what's winning out you
bring up a really good point I mean we
are to be preparing our hearts for
Christ's second coming right and if we
are literally sitting and running around
going I don't have time I don't have
time enough time for this but we find
time for all of these distractions in
life then you really have to question at
the end of the day I mean that's a
really good point where you spend your
time where your heart is there your
treasure will be also there are people
who spend lots of money on things that
would be considered their vices or
addictions and then they need help with
the necessities like food and other
things and it's like well you know
what's winning out here you know if we
room we shift where our priorities are
you would have plenty of money yeah good
point good point
listen know what the Bible says about
our time look carefully then how you
walk not as the unwise but as the wise
making the best use of time because the
days are evil yeah this is super
interesting because now it's not just
putting this into the context of
you know is it okay to play a video game
or not yeah there are plenty of good
games they could probably teach you
something now it's adding a different
factor because of the time that we live
in so even something that could be good
you have to sit there and evaluate is
this the best use of my time because of
the time that we live in so you know and
if it is fair enough it is you know if
if cut the rope helps you concentrate
all day long and you absolutely need
that you see these improvements and
you're playing it for five minutes or
something okay you know but if if
there's other things you know you can do
to help concentrate you know and and and
it comes between that and maybe
something else I give it convinced
between that and your Bible study then
you know the days are evil better to put
what's you know the Word of God in your
mind then then maybe you play that game
I like how the Bible equates us to don't
be unwise yeah don't be wise you know
wise people learned how to use their
time you sit down you read any of those
entrepreneurial magazines or you know
out of this guy become a billionaire
they knew what to do with their time it
did not waste idle moments doing things
that literally profit you nothing and
that's what I think is is the most
interesting thing with the video game
world I mean it is like BF Skinner right
it's like like pushing the little lever
oh I got five hundred and thirty sixty
thousand points what does that do for
you just triggering dopamine does
nothing for you so you know think about
think about that where do you use your
time I want to leave you with this one
last verse the night is far spent the
day is at hand let us therefore cast off
the works of darkness and let us put on
the armor of light says Romans 1312
what is the armor of God let me get the
helmet of salvation that was me yeah
who's this salvation Christ Jesus it's
right
you've got the belt of truth who's the
definition of truth that's Jesus you
know you got the gospel of peace that's
like the shoes the Prince of Peace
that's Jesus all of the elements that
are for the armor is literally learning
how to put on
and I bring that up because I want to
like you know it sounds very simple and
basic but if you're sitting there
playing a video game and you can imagine
like playing that video game with Jesus
or you've put on Jesus and you're
running around would you be killing
people and dancing over their dead
bodies you know I mean if you're putting
on Christ then we would not be doing
these works of darkness I hope you guys
had a blessed time watching this led
live we've got a lot more of these shows
once again I want to remind you thank
you so much for those of you that have
jumped on and supported us through
patreon you are the reason we are able
to do what we are doing and we want to
thank you guys so much if you haven't
jumped on and seen what we got with
patreon I suggest you do so we've got
some really cool perks you get some
behind-the-scenes stuff also check out
our videos that we have on our website
little eyed studios TV hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
and hit that notification bell so when
we drop new videos you guys will be the
first to get notified that new video is
coming out we want to thank you guys so
much for watching our videos and if you
have any suggestions obviously leave
them in the comments below and we will
catch you next Friday hey guys please
don't forget to stop by school for
prophecy TV this is where you can find
the first 15 minutes of from America to
babble and you can stream it now for a
donation of $1 99 and the donation is
gonna go towards the next film babbling
the great [__]
[Music]